this video was made possible by
brilliant org be one of the first 200
people to sign up using the link in the
description and save 20% on your premium
subscription today
[Music]
[Music]
after 10 long days on the road visiting
family I finally made it home and mostly
recovered all that driving and watching
the miles add up made me wonder how does
the average modern road trip compared to
the distance traveled by history's
greatest explorers let's start by
looking at my route I started out in
your Dallas Texas drove 812 miles to
Atlanta Georgia
then 661 miles from Atlanta to Baltimore
Maryland then 792 miles from Baltimore
to Paducah Kentucky and finally 670
miles from Paducah back to Texas from
start to finish
I traveled just about 3,000 miles that's
a pretty good distance but how does it
stack up against the world's most
distinguished travelers let's start with
Christopher Columbus in case you don't
remember from school Christopher
Columbus was the Explorer that traveled
from Spain to find a faster trade route
to India and the Orient eventually
discovering what was then called the new
world what we know as the Americas one
of his four voyages nearly ended in
mutiny because Columbus had made some
pretty serious errors while attempting
to determine the distance from Spain to
their destination to buy some time
Columbus told the crew that if they
hadn't sighted land in two days they
would turn back luckily they spotted
land the next day the famous voyage that
culminated in the discovery of the new
world is estimated to have been
approximately 13,000 342 miles in
distance okay that's a pretty big number
almost four and a half times the
distance of my road trip and it took him
about four months it would be pretty
hard to beat 13,000 342 miles in a
single road trip but according to the US
Department of Transportation every year
the average American actually drives
farther than Columbus sailed it might
take us three times as long to do it but
Americans average 13,000 476 miles each
year if you did want to beat Columbus's
voyage in one trip you do have a couple
options first this monstrosity this
crazy road trip was designed to be the
most efficient way to visit 50 national
landmarks within the 48 contiguous
United States at a whopping thirteen
thousand six hundred ninety nine miles
its creator estimates it would take
without traffic 224 hours of driving or
9.3 full 24 hour days to finish it a
realistic estimate would be more along
the lines of two to three months to
actually do it and enjoy the experience
if you decided to tackle the landmark
road trip you could officially say you
traveled a greater distance faster than
the man credited with discovering North
America if you wanted to add another
trophy to your collection you could
drive another 4,000 miles or so to outdo
Ferdinand Magellan or rather the small
number of his crew that survived the
first expedition to circumnavigate the
globe Magellan set sail from Spain in
1519 with a fleet of five ships hoping
to discover a western sea route to the
Spice Islands of the 270 crew members
that set out at the end of the three
year journey only eighteen men remained
Magellan himself was killed by a poison
arrow during a battle with Island
natives all in all the length of the
expedition totalled an impressive 18,000
95 miles to beat that distance you'd
have to complete the enormous landmark
road trip and then drive across the
entire United States coast-to-coast
twice the shortest distance from one
coast of the US to the other is about
2,000 miles if you do decide to dethrone
Magellan just make sure you don't pick a
fight with any locals lest you repeat
history even more well-traveled than
those on the Magellan expedition was
Venetian merchant marco polo polo spent
24 years of his life cataloguing his
adventures in china including his
experiences with Kublai Khan son of the
legendary jingis Khan these epic tales
would later inspire another Explorer on
our list Christopher Columbus over his
24 years of travel and adventure Marco
Polo had accumulated an amazing 20 3339
miles
mostly over land to beat polos distance
you'd have to start with the landmark
road trip and then tackle the crazy
Mongol Rally heralded as the greatest
adventure in the world the Mongol Rally
is a 10,000 mile Odyssey across the
mountains desert and steppe throughout
Europe and Asia terminating in the
Russian city of Gulen du-de of course a
10,000 mile journey across 22 countries
would be too easy without a few more
restrictions to take part in the annual
rally you have to raise $1,000 for
charity and find a cheap sub
ten-year-old car with a 1.2 liter engine
or smaller if you can tackle the Mongol
Rally and the u.s. landmark road trip in
under 24 years
congratulations you've traveled farther
and faster than the legendary Marco Polo
finally there's one adventurer on our
list that you'd really really have to
try to top and you've probably never
heard of
born in 1906 canadian-american Idris
Welsh would go on to adopt the name
aloha wander well and drive over 500,000
miles in early Ford automobiles as a
teenager wander well joined an
expedition to travel the world by Ford
Model T Model A and the later touring
sedan she and her first husband cap
wander well recorded their adventures on
sixteen and thirty five millimeter film
in locations across 80 countries and 6
continents always in their trusty Fords
Aloha was the first woman to
circumnavigate the world by car and all
of her films now reside in the Hollywood
Academy Film Archives so still want to
take her title of 500,000 miles here's
how you do it step one complete the US
landmark road trip step two defeat the
mighty Mongol Rally step three
survive the 30 thousand mile behemoth
that is the pan-american highway
starting way up in Deadhorse Alaska and
ending up all the way down into swaiiow
Argentina those three trips will rack up
an impressive 53 thousand six hundred
ninety nine miles just over a hundred
miles fewer than Columbus Magellan and
polo combined but that still nowhere
near Aloha wander wells mileage you'd
have to complete those three giant road
trips ten times to claim the trophy of
being more adventurous than the world's
most widely traveled woman could you do
it with enough time and dedication sure
just don't expect me to go with you even
if I do drive a Ford if you wanted to
learn about the issues you would face on
a road trip with friends or your spouse
it doesn't matter that five percent of
road trips result in irreparable harm to
the relationship or any number of other
facts what matters is the actual road
trip that you take and how you react to
it I'm sure most of us agree that the
best way to learn anything is by
actually doing it yourself for all the
students and young professionals in my
audience and I know there are a lot of
you whether you're struggling to make
sense of math or want to challenge your
understanding of physics brilliant org
has the best way for you to learn by
actually solving interesting puzzles
what better way to build up your
understanding of a concept than learning
how to think like a scientist put
yourself in Christopher Columbus's shoes
if you didn't trust the contemporary
estimates of the Earth's diameter
brilliant could help guide you in
understanding how to make these
calculations so you wouldn't have
drastically underestimated the length of
the
and ended up with a mutinous crew the
great part is even when you get a
question wrong
brilliant tells you exactly why your
answer was incorrect and shows you the
steps to finding the right solution as a
little thank you for watching my videos
the first 200 people to sign up at
brilliant org slash second thought will
get 20% off their premium subscription
so if you want to avoid a mutiny on your
next road trip and learn about
fascinating subjects in math and science
be sure to check out brilliance courses
at brilliant org slash second thought if
you enjoyed this video consider
subscribing to support the channel and
stay up to date on the latest content
and click the little bell next to my
channel name to join the notification
squad you can watch my previous video by
clicking here or if you're done learning
for the day come watch me play games
with a friend on my new gaming channel
thanks for watching and I'll see you in
the next video